um welcome back for the second session
um we are delighted to continue the
conversation hopefully inside the room
not outside um so we set up for a great
uh two-hander session so I'm going to
start by introducing our first speaker
um and then after that we'll jump
directly to my colleague Nick who will
introduce Esther and then we'll take
question s um from both of them at the
end of it so uh Lucas Shanel is an
associate professor at CNP Paris he's
actually visiting Harvard Kenley School
this year so we were lucky to be able to
um get him to come his research focuses
on global in inequality and
environmental policy and he is the
co-director and and Senior Economist at
the world inequal inequality Lab at the
Paris School of Economics so
Lucas morning everybody delighted to
here um and would like to to to thank
the the organizers of this of this great
conference my talk is entitled
addressing inequality under climate
change issues in measurement and policy
and I would like to start with some of
the introductory remarks and comments
made by rohini earlier today I think the
the introductory remarks stressed one of
the key achievements of the past um
three decades which is this reduction of
global poverty in by historic
um um quantities by historic numbers
sorry um at the same
time and is this at sorry at the same
time um despite this strong reduction in
global poverty which is one of these
very positive traits of um globalization
of over the past three decades economic
inequality remains very large globally
and the world is still very very far
from being flat as it had been uh
assumed that it would be uh um in in
some discourses three or four uh decades
ago there are still huge uh numbers of
people in extreme poverty who might also
live side by side with uh people with um
very high levels of wealth and affluence
and
so what we've also observed over the
past three decades is this rise of
inequality within major economies in the
global North and in the global
South climate change tends to
exacerbate economic inequality Trends
between countries and I'll be saying a
few words about
that it also affects inequality Trends
within countries and it makes more
challenging the growth of a global
middle
class and so the question that I'm going
to ask in the coming um uh 15 minutes is
how to address inequality on the warming
planet and um and so to um to Kickstart
this this discussion I'm I'm drawing uh
from a a few numbers from the world
inequality Report with um my colleagues
Tom piki Emanuel SE and and Gabriel
zuckman where we show here um the level
of income inequality on your left and
the level of wealth inequality in the
world on the right hand side of the
graph so at the global level the top 10%
of income earners make about
50% of all incomes and the bottom 50% of
the world distribution make a little
less than 10% of all incomes when it
comes to wealth inequality the picture
is uh more extreme so to say the top 10%
of wealth owners own close to three4 of
everything there is to own on this
planet and the bottom half of the world
distribution owns just
2% of global
wealth um so that's the key basic
starting point of the discussion that I
will try to uh to pursue today another
important fact I think is that
inequality has been rising in many large
uh countries or economies over the past
three or four decades and here you see
the top 10% national income share across
a few regions or countries North America
in blue Europe in green Russia Central
Asia in purple China and India in red
and yellow on this uh graph one of the
key insights from this literature and
economic inequality is that inequality
has been rising but it has been rising
at different speeds and so the this
means that there are actually different
ways to open up to uh International
Trade there are different ways to
embrace new technologies there are are
different way ways to navigate uh this
uh changing world and to reduce poverty
as well and I think this is going to be
one of the argument that I will try to
make when it comes to uh tackling
climate change and to dealing with the
inequality issues associated with
climate change
there are different ways in which we can
actually do the energy
transition and the question um here is
how is climate change intersecting with
economic inequality or perhaps more
generally with inequalities in human
development and so
um the discussion on climate change and
inequality has been and this was also uh
uh stressed in the introduction for a
long time focused on inequity between
Generations between now and the future
for uh some time now Scholars have been
starting to focus more on the Now
problem inequalities within a generation
and here I'd like to to borrow some um
word first B point from from Boyce in
his book 2002 stressing that pollution
is ultimately about winners and losers
without losers whether humans or
non-humans alive or yet to be born
without losers there's no
pollution but there's no pollution
either without winners otherwise either
it's a trivial problem or uh it's uh not
going to be uh sustained for a long time
so it is a distributional matter it is a
distributional issue with winners and
losers now when trying to measure it or
to analyze um pollution from an
inequality perspective there might might
be different ways to think about it
there are different dimensions global
scale national scale subnational scale
micro
level different
metrics monetary physical social
demographic and different types of um
effects that we might be looking at or
Dimensions here inequality in terms of
impacts who is impacted by climate
change by environmental
change or different ways to contribute
to the problem who is polluting in what
quantities through which pollutants but
also inequality in capacity to face
environmental changes or inequalities in
capacity to face policies that
addressal changes I think the echo has
come back right very much actually it is
growing
so shall we make a pause to or shall I
continue
okay so let me just finish this slide uh
by saying that this is a burgeoning
field in the social sciences and uh in
which interdisciplinary research is
Paramount and that's a good news I think
is an exciting news for uh a diverse
audience of of Scholars of researchers
um like the one here today one of the
key issues is
that these analysis these metrics on
environmental inequalities on carbon
inequalities pollution inequalities are
often missing from official statistics
they're still not quite present in the
dashboards used by governments to think
about environmental policy or to think
about economic and social policy and now
I think that the echo has actually ended
so thank you thank you very much uh for
for that and so what I will try to focus
on in the next um few minutes we'll draw
from um a few recent papers that are
written down here plus uh some broader
work from the climate inequality
literature that will also refer to and
the starting point is what um we call
here with my colleague Philip B and T V
the tribal climate inequality crisis so
here we try to represent three
dimensions of global climate inequality
not necessarily exhaustive but we think
they map a fairly uh um good amount of
types of inequalities we might want to
think about in red you have the
inequality in relative losses associated
with climate change by relative losses
here I mean that we look at income
losses of individuals but we're
controlling for average income
differences between countries okay so
these are relative income losses after
having controlled for differences in
average income between countries and so
here we see that the bottom
50% of emitters at the global level
um in fact um make up three4 of all
relative income losses associated with
climate change the second dimension in
green is the inequality in emissions in
pollution some have called this type of
inequality an an inequality in gains
there are losers and there are winners
and so pollution can also be seen or
contributions to CO2 emissions can also
be seen as uh
mapping fairly well the gains associated
with uh with climate change and with
this pollution and so here the other
inequality that is represented here is
uh this one by which the top 10% of
global emitters represent more or less a
little less than 50% of all uh emissions
and then the third um category here is
the inequality Inc capacity to finance
the transition or the inequality to face
um inability to face uh climate policies
to be resilient in the face of it and
here this uh this is basically
relatively badly proxied so to say and I
think there's much more work to be done
on the matter by basically the
inequality in wealth ownership at the
global level level so basically
restating what I was showing before the
top 10% of wealth owners make around 3
quarters of uh Global uh wealth so that
is the that is the general uh framework
of this of this uh intervention today I
will be looking at these three types of
climate inequalities and for each type I
will review some key findings from uh
from Recent research and discuss some
issues associated with uh the current
state of thinking
so unequal losses um GDP uh impacts
associated with temperature increases
have been found to be quite unequally um
spread across the world with climate
change tending to exacerbate inequality
between countries and so tropical and
subtropical Nations appear to be more
impacted by climate change by the
climate change that has already been
happening and this is largely through
the channel of uh AG agricultural
productivity impacts which we've
discussed earlier uh
today now um it is also quite and so we
may want to discuss how sorry how these
uh these estimates are produced what are
the underlying models uh used to uh to
produce such estimates um however this
inequality of um acts I think is is
something that is uh uh quite well um
established as well as the fact that
within countries not just between
countries but within countries poorest
groups tend to be more
exposed to environmental changes to
environmental damage and when
environmental damage uh hits populations
poor poorest groups are also more
vulnerable to it and so uh this leads to
a um climate change leading to higher
inequalities within countries as well
and here Alat and Rosenberg for instance
have this uh interesting result looking
at household surveys for uh dozens of
countries and simulating uh shocks
associated with environmental damages
they find that the bottom 50 40% of the
distribution loses 70% more than the
average due to environmental shock so
the bottom 40% the poorest groups of the
population more impacted by the average
by the way that kind of study here looks
at developing countries but um the
literature has also found that this is
not just a developing country
characteristic we also see strong
climate inequalities and impacts in rich
countries as well uh so it has been
shown for instance that heat waves are
going to hit social uh economically most
uh deprived group more than the average
for instance and here I'm just referring
to this uh work by abovich and
co-authors where uh they look at
differences between low-income High
income women men individuals when it
comes to the effect of heat exposure on
uh the probability of reporting mental
health issues and so this is also maybe
an area where more work can be done to
uh make such results even more granular
and more precise but there's a strong
case here of intersection between uh
gender class and climate
inequalities now some issues in this uh
in this uh inequality of losses uh
stream of the literature I think is that
standard approaches to measuring climate
risk or climate impact can lead to
mistargeting so here what this global
map shows is the economic value at risk
of flooding across the world measured in
US dollar purchas in power parity and so
you see some form of distribution of
these losses across the globe uh now
when the question you're going to ask
might be a question of what's the number
of people in poverty that are affected
the map might look pretty radically
different here so here this is the
population share which is below dollar
1.9 perity threshold and which is also
at flood risk so we have a very
different representation of what this
inequality is about so I think that uh
what I've been trying to discuss here is
that um there's this need for very
granular data we've been looking at that
earlier today and I think there is a
strong evolution in uh recent work here
also mobilizing uh large large scale
satellite imagery uh to to look at these
issues um but there's also a need for
the use of a combination of monetary and
non-monetary metrics to understand these
inequalities and so this is again this
strong call for uh even more
interdisciplinary research on the matter
uh the challenges ahead I think again
connecting with some of the discussion
earlier today is how to produce
real-time estimates how to produce
forecasts that can be used by policy to
Target their social policy measures for
instance to anticipate climate shocks
and their impacts and also how to think
about and how to measure the joint
distribution of consumption of income
and capital and how these are impacted
by uh climate change and this is
something which I think uh still quite a
bit of work uh can be done it's already
quite difficult to measure the
consumption of income capital and
consumption jointly and it's even more
complex to uh simulate or to uh estimate
how climate change might affect these uh
distributions now let me look at the
inequality of contributions so um the
inequality of contributions so that was
my green bars here the first way to look
at the problem is really the this
historical inequality of contributions
here so over 1850 to
2020 uh North America and Europe
represented about half of all emissions
and so the key question is how to split
the remaining budget across countries
and across individuals but this first
big dimension of uh inequality of
contributions another way to look at
this is to look at the inequality in
average contributions across uh the
world so global average uh ghg emissions
per capita um around six six tons uh per
person uh in
2019 with subsaharan Africa around 1.6
tons per person per year on average and
North America a little more than 20 tons
per person per year on
average um now sorry one of the big
question is then how we going to split
this these averages across the
distribution so not looking just as at
averages but looking at the inequality
between between individuals there are
many different ways to do it the bottom
line I'd like to to say is in this graph
these are results for bottom 50% middle
40% top 10 top 1% um so these are the
share in total emissions the results
from different studies the bottom line
is that these various studies mobilizing
different types of methodologies seem to
come up with relatively similar
numbers and what are these numbers the
top
10% of the distribution of income
earners or cons or consumers or emitters
represent more or less 45% of all
emissions and the bottom half of the
world
population emits between 7 7% and 15% of
the total so that's uh relatively uh
standard result in this literature
another uh result um this one from one
specific study and uh with all due
respect for primee Minister andira gandi
that was referred to earlier um in fact
what we see here is that poverty in
itself is not the big chunk of the
problem at the global level when it
comes to uh CO2 emissions here bottom
50% of the world population less than
10% of emissions but even the
eradication of extreme poverty itself
would not represent according to
Brookner and co-author such a big uh
increase in uh overall emissions so this
is top 1% emissions compared with
emissions required to eradicate
1.9 or $3.2 uh doll uh poverty so the
big question is the growth of the middle
class it is not the eradication of uh
extreme poverty now another result from
this literature I think is uh that there
has been somewhat of a big shift in the
relative importance of between versus
within country carbon inequality over
the past four decades so this is a tile
index decomposition of the global
inequality in individual carbon
emissions and so according to these
results uh in the early
1990s a little more than 60% of global
inequality is due to between country
differences so to average differences
between China and us Europe uh for
instance this inequity has been reducing
over time and now we are in a world
where most of the um inequality most of
global carbon inequality is due to
within country differences this doesn't
mean that there aren't big differences
in average emission levels between
regions and I referred to one of the
earlier graphs I've presented but it
means that on top of this we're now in a
world where there's also quite a big
amount of inequalities within
countries um Let Me In the interest of
time
so two minutes three
minutes all right in the interest time
just maybe flagging some uh key issues
in this uh in this literature on the
attribution of emissions to individuals
it is quite straightforward to
attribute direct emissions to
individuals or to households so think
about the carbon that you emit when you
use your uh your car that uses gasoline
or think about the emissions from your
gas heater for instance that's really
easy to to attribute to individuals when
it comes to attributing all
emissions within uh that are associated
with production processes to individuals
it's more
complicated one of the uh the ipcc gives
basically two two Criterion to do so one
is that of exclusivity you don't want to
count the same T ton of carbon twice for
two different actors but also of you
need to be comprehensive so you want to
count direct and also indirect emissions
and to do this in a systematic framework
uh at the level of a country as a whole
and even more at the level of the world
is quite challenging and so the standard
approach to that has been to distribute
all emissions to Consumers using input
output tabl so TR trade tables uh
connected with uh uh pollution data and
to allocate all these emissions to
Consumers and I think that's a a a a
good way to proceed at the same time
this um tends to miss the role of
savings the rol of
investors uh in uh in driving emissions
or in driving
decarbonization this tends to omit the
fact that as consumer
we sometimes have limited information
limited agency and so um this approach
to measuring emissions solely focused on
consumer is actually uh in some ways
limited and just to give you an inside
of uh of what I'm trying to say here
this is the distribution of carbon
footprint in the US uh in 2019 that's a
consumer perspective full population a
little more than 20 tons per person per
year the top 10% of the population here
is a little above 50 tons per person per
year now if I'm doing the same thing so
attributing us emissions to us
individuals if I'm attributing direct
emissions again to those who are
responsible for these direct emissions
but if I'm attributing emissions from
production processes in a different way
not to the final consumers of goods but
to the owners of the industries that
pollute this is the kind of picture that
I would have the top
10% uh in that in that case um emits 100
tons of CO2 per person per so a factor
two different so this is and I'll skip
all this in the interest of time just to
say that uh the consumption approach has
been very useful to think about
emissions responsibility and inequality
but it might be quite limited and better
measuring emissions associated with
wealth is key this might uh lead us to
having other new insights of how to
think about the incidence of carbon
taxes and of regulations and I will skip
the final part which was really about
this uh Third Dimension here the
capacity to finance maybe just by saying
that we might think from this graph that
this is essentially a global North
versus global South issue capital is in
the north and relative losses are in the
South however there are also very large
wealth inequalities in each region of
the world so even in Europe which is a
relatively equal region in this world uh
the bottom 50% of the population owns
less than 5% of uh wealth so this has
implications in how we going to think
about Bridging the global climate
Finance Gap who should bridge this Gap
private actors public actors uh how to
think about that in a context of strong
relatively strong inequalities and how
to think about that in a context where
the Investments we make today are not
only going to determine the ecological
state of the world in the future but
also contribute to shape economic
inequalities in the decades to come
thank you very much for your
[Applause]
attention
so uh wonderful um thank you for this um
introduction and sort of tour of the
facts on climate inequality in
particular this focus on Bridging the
Gap so we're now going to kind of turn
the attention um in the conference
towards exactly that uh what can
governments and markets do to address
some of the problems that we've seen in
these first two sessions um and to kick
that off I'm very pleased to introduce
Professor Esther Duo uh Professor Duo is
the Abdul Latif Jamil professor of
development economics and poverty
alleviation in the department of
Economics at MIT uh she's the co-founder
and co-director of the Abdul La J
poverty action lab uh which really sort
of LED uh the innovation of using
randomized experiments as we saw in the
first session in development economics
and her own research has spanned uh an
incredible range of topics within
development from credit and finance uh
to education and health governance um
inequality uh and environment as well uh
as well as contributions to empirical
methods so uh this is really a
remarkable um set of work and it's been
recognized broadly in including with the
inaugural 2008 BBVA frontiers of
knowledge award and the 2019 Nobel prize
in economics so it's a great pleasure
please please welcome Professor
[Applause]
Duo uh thank you thank you so much um
and by way of preliminary if you be like
an interloper I have done some work on
environment with Nick with ro uh um
among others but it's been some time and
um and what I'm going to talk about
today involves almost no randomized
control trial it has some plug for them
uh so I I kind of uh one of these uh
older people who use their their
previous work to justify shouting their
mouth about everything so I apologize
for that but
um a lot of what I'm going to say are
things that you guys know uh but maybe a
that's also giving kind of a way of
packaging it for the rest of the world
which might also be help ful and some of
you represent the rest of the world so
you can be my test
audience
um so oops that's not the yes that's the
one I want I want to start with John
Gary uh so this is uh kind of what we
have to when we you know motivated by
Lucas's talk or the talk this mon
earlier this morning we might think that
you know one of the key question we have
to address is what is our respons what
is the responsibility of the rich World
Vis A the poor part of the world or Rich
citizen is a v a poor Citizen and uh it
doesn't start very well because the the
climate Envoy of the US is that uh you
know sets the stage in June by
testifying in front of Congress that the
US under no circumstances will pay
climate reparations so uh you would
think that's not a very good it's kind
of a pretty clear way to start the
negotiations uh for
um uh kind of the the sharing of the
both the mitigation of climate change
moving forward and the the cost of the
adaptation uh that is already
happening uh but I think it is very
important to just take that as a given
because I think it is true the US will
under no circumstance bation so I think
it's just as a positive matter at a
normative level we of course should you
might disagree at a POS level I think
it's helpful to take that under
advisement and said this is not
happening but of course it's not just
about past responsibility so it's not
just about reparations because as Lucas
told us the the emission responsible for
climate change are mainly due uh to the
current behavior of Rich citizens most
of which although not all of which are
in rich
countries uh I plan to spend very little
time on this because uh uh I knew that L
was before me but I think one point that
was not he didn't highlight as much as
he does in in in most of his work and
which is really essential to remind
people although I do
know uh in this uh you know the second
line after the US will pay reparation
and no circumstance is usually well yes
historically it was us but now look at
China they are in they they are they are
the ones they are the problem so unless
China uh uh fixes their uh emission
problem then you know there's nothing we
you know it's going to be limited what
can be done you hear a lot of that in
Europe which is kind of self-righteous
feeling that we're already kind of ahead
in the in the combat so yes you know but
you know China and then the US of course
and then India they are the one who are
meeting already a lot and more and more
so frankly this is to them toward them
that you have to uh uh uh Focus your
attention uh but of course uh um China
and India are producing a lot of goods
that are then consumed uh uh in the rest
of the world and China and India are net
CO2 exporters and USA is a very big
importer and so is Europe uh so in other
word when we thinking about using this
input output tables to think about the
full carbon footprint of a person we
need to take into account when they
drive their electric car uh they are uh
the the full carbon footprint of someone
is
whatever went to produce said electric
car you all know that is so obvious that
Lucas didn't remind us this is how we
are trying to uh that it needs to be
comp computed but that's not the the the
the headline numbers uh when we think
about emission that that that uh come to
the news it's not the consumption
emission let alone the wealth emission
uh it's just the emission so so I think
a first thing is to remind that it's a a
lot of work obviously to do properly uh
but as Luc emphasized many people have
done it several not many but several
groups have done it and in particular he
cited Brookner and himself the
methodology are really different to
arrive at very similar results both of
them are have a lot of assumptions you
might quibble with all of the
assumptions but the fact that they lead
to very similar result is
encouraging um Lucas was a bit more
subtle in describing his own results
than I will be but I like to remind them
by this 1050 rule 10% of the highest
polluter worldwi are responsible for
almost 50 for about 50% almost 50% of
global emission and conversely 50% of
the lowest polluters are responsible for
about 10% of global emission it didn't
have to be that way in fact it's not
exactly that way uh but it's easy to to
remember uh since we have a Brookner uh
uh Brookner is the worldbe the team uh
found very similar results uh and they
have a nice map so I thought I I would
switch to them uh and then when you look
at where these people are located it is
true that there is rich people in who
who emit a lot in India and China in the
Middle East also but it is it tends to
be the case that uh High polluters
mainly live in rich countries um so this
is the map of the carbon footprint and
of course the S region of Africa that we
heard about this morning is entirely
blue uh while the US is is bright red
and uh with that notion of emission uh
Europe is actually kind of orangish
where it would look better if we didn't
include uh consumption uh if we didn't
include kind of imputed emission from
what we
consume uh this is something Lucas has
already said which is which is quite
important uh
I I'll show you a little bit later but
again it was mentioned this morning and
and you all know that there is a lot of
kind of emphasis on mitigation effort in
poor countries and this idea that there
would be a tradeoff between uh reducing
poverty and uh uh and um and and
fighting and avoiding making climate
change worth but first order because
people in Africa emit almost nothing
even if their income were to doubled
that would really not make a big
difference so it's kind of a non
discussion to have and for a non
discussion it has a lot of place in the
public discussion uh so one summary of
this of this of this first discussion so
look at at even a smaller number but so
the way I read this is that eradicating
extreme poverty so making nobody lives
under $2 a day would increase emissions
by only 2% uh this is probably
represents you know a tiny amount tiny
fraction of what richest people in the
world consume so we can kind of forget
that tradeoff in the sense that first
order uh um first of all uh poor people
are extremely poor and need to be less
poor now second of all even if we only
were worrying about climate uh of course
being being poor is a pretty bad deal to
uh to be protected against climate A
first order way of adapting to climate
change is to have a bit more money so
that you can you don't have to work when
it's very hard you can adapt your
production and so on and so forth so
that is kind of a first point I wanted
to make the second point is uh again as
Lucas al already said the cost of
climate change are going to be felt in
the poorer part of the world he
emphasized income and I want to
emphasize mortality
from the work by you know people in this
home at Global impact lab but the first
the first order point of course poor
country are in places that are already
hot uh so this is temperature today um
and
therefore even though you know suppose
the the Earth warms by two degrees it's
not going to be two degrees absolutely
everywhere but just to simplify imagine
that's the case if you're in a place
where there are already many very hot
days then you're going to get more of
those hot
days uh and then of the impact of uh
temperature on the human body's ability
to uh thbe and then to survive is not
linear in particular you know above 30
32 in particular if it's a little bit
humid on top of that is where it becomes
uh just not very conial for for human
life and you're going to see more of
those hot days in poor countries
uh already we see them more today I
realize that I I I'm keeping under
advisement from this morning using the
fact it's happening today already but
you know this is 2050 soon enough you're
going to get more of the hot days I
should note this is uh um the the north
of Latin America is also to be uh kind
of gets very red in these places and by
I think I skipped one slide well by 2000
it's even more hot days and you see a
huge concentration of the number of very
hot days uh uh in places that are very
poor in particular Subs Africa but also
Pakistan uh and the uh the northeast of
Brazil for example the second point also
from uh uh T celton and others uh uh
this big uh great group of people at
Chicago looking at and kind of a lot of
people they work with
all over have used historical data to uh
uh try and compute the the the cost
again in term of human or of human
mortality of an extra hot days so what
you can do is to say well it's been you
know in the past around the climate
there is variation from year to year
take a particular District in India
where there are more hot days uh do more
people die compared to a very similar
District where in these particular years
there are fewer hes so that's we can use
this historical data to give us an idea
of the impact of temperature and
mortality I should say this is really
variation around business as usual it
doesn't include any of the disaster that
we're going to get to as well
flooding and this type you know fire
this type of stuff it's just temperature
so this is very much lower bound but
we're going to stick with that for the
moment
and uh so what they what they're uh do
doing in their QJ paper is to look at uh
bunch of micro regions they are fewer
than that there is a bit of
interpolation involved in that and then
separating countries by Cold countries
hot countries medium temperate countries
and then poor country rich country are
medium countries and two things first of
all in places that are very uh cold uh
when it gets hot suddenly a lot of
people die because the places are not
used to to that so uh a few now almost a
decade ago there was a massive Heatwave
in France and many many people died
because we were so unprepared in the
subsequent Heat Wave we did much better
because we kind of knew what to do with
that and visit the old people and bring
them to Cinemas or Museum or so on so
that's the first thing the second thing
is that in places which are poor uh
mortality is much higher for H days and
this is because uh you don't have you
poor people tend to work outside uh poor
people do not have air conditioning so
you take a very hot day in Texas and
people go from their air conditioning
home into their air conditioning car
into their air conditioning office and
they don't die but your very very hot
day in Pakistan and then uh people are
working in a heat and they have hit
stroke and they
die so when you combine all of that this
is what this graph summar when you
combined all of that you get this Maps
which is the mortality effect of a
particular hot day you know one more hot
day 35° so of course in you know in
Greenland it would be very uh people if
there were people in Greenland they
would die when it's very hot but they
are not going to be very many hot days
in Greenland uh but then in Subs Africa
where we already see that there would be
a lot of hot days then a lot of people
will die too uh because because they are
poor so when you combine the fact that
that uh uh
oops I'm not doing very well with the
slide yes that's the one one when you
combine the
two uh you the fact that there will be
more hot days in uh poor places that
already poor and these hot days will
create more uh death uh you get this map
uh also from that same QJ paper which is
by
2100 uh so maybe it's too far in the
future for us to think because I think
we probably could do something already
like that there but it's very striking
which is you have this big red blood
blood in in uh basically Kelsey's
fieldwalk the whole the S region of
Africa but also the north of of of South
Asia and then most of the oecd is blue
which means that climate change will
actually save save lives in uh in rich
countries so just just so you don't get
the message that you we have no nothing
to worry about in rich countries this is
just temperature that there is all these
other things there will be damage in
rich countries but from temperature
alone actually if you just look at the
mortality impact of temperature the
impact will be concentrated in poor
countries so the estimate is that in the
business as usual scenario the RCP 8.5
there would be 73 extra deaths per
100,000 people 2100 so and of course in
the middle we'll walk through that um
exclusively in poor
countries that's more than all of the uh
death from infectious diseases today so
it's like you know take uh all of HIV
tuberculosis Etc that's going to be more
than
that uh so this makes for in a sense I'm
just repeating in different ways what
Lucas said but this makes it for very
thorny political issues because first
there in the next many years the
problems are going to be felt in in poor
countries uh at least the kind of first
problem of being alive but the principal
margin of actions are in the South
because this is where people are are in
the north sorry because this is where uh
the the highest emitters are
located uh so is it the case that until
now we've uh displayed a great capacity
to deal with this kind of issue
that's a bit of a rhetorical question uh
because we have the recent experience of
covid which was a problem which in a
sense come from the north and was
exported to the South when it came
originally from China but it's not that
there was even that much Co in Africa
but we told them you have to lock down
your economy
right um so this was this problem that
was at least a global problem and there
were really two two Dimensions one where
we um the kind of the world could have
globally acted one was Financial
transfers and the other was vaccines uh
on financial transfers uh there was
almost no increase in bilateral or
multilateral fund flows towards the poor
countries so while uh the rich world was
doing whatever it takes to get out of it
so the the countries in the rich worlds
this is a map from the IMF about how
much uh countries spend in fiscal
stimulus meas me so the countries uh in
the rich World spend about 27% of their
GDP in fiscal stimulus measures uh the
poorest country in the world spend 2% of
their GDP in fiscal stimulus measur and
of course the GDP is much smaller so
basically the smaller countries weren't
able to to do much to help their uh
their citizens adjust which led to this
increase in poverty in uh in poor
countries which had no equivalent in
richer countries
and uh it would really have cost almost
nothing it would have hardly registered
to uh borrow a little more on top of the
trillions we were B anyways to bring
Togo at 27% of their GDP because the GDP
of Togo is so small that this would you
know we would kind of hardly have seen
the difference but this didn't happen at
all uh so that's the first point the
second case of course which was widely
publicized is the the the the inability
to uh to secure vaccine early in the
pandemic for the poor countries despite
having an institution to do that which
was kovax which was set up to do that
and proceeded to be unable to buy doses
because the rich countries had been
holding them
so when this was happening I my take on
that was like oh wow it's pretty bad
first of all it's pretty bad and second
of all it really sends a terrible signal
about the ab ability of the world to
share solutions to to problems and it's
going to be very costly for climate
change moving forward and of course I
didn't know about Ukraine yet but I
think we've seen the direct consequences
for example in African countries refusal
to to to engage very much with what
Europe or the US had to say on
Ukraine uh there at the moment seems to
be a bit of stand stand still in the at
least Under Pressure the the world
getting together to uh to uh uh share
Solutions and problems that's a
uh
uh so where are we after many many cops
um so that's a maybe an unfair
characterization of where we are uh not
enough money going towards low and
middle income countries the commitments
are too weak and they are not carried
out or they are not renewed
uh there was a 100 billion pledge in cup
uh in Copenhagen many many years ago
which was never fulfilled I'll show you
slides in a minute and to the extent
that they spent that money was sent
towards developing countries it's mostly
loans and mostly mitigation which is
nice enough but that's kind of neither
here nor there Visa uh the the cost that
we are
implying then there was a cup 27
reparation fund it came without
financing then there was a bit of Deb
lock maybe it was Dead on Arrival it as
it turns out not almost as timely as the
social cost of carbon on November 6 uh a
basic agreement to have a fund hosted at
the World Bank as an interim trustee was
reached but uh at the beest of the US
there there's no obligation for anybody
to contribute to such fund uh so the
agreement encourage but does not oblig
all country to contribute to the fund so
the developing countries are very the
low low-income countries are very upset
because the fund is in the world bank
and the rich the the US made sure that
nobody really had to contribute to it so
it's it's seems that there is a bit of
work to uh to continue to um uh to work
on that um I'll St the on on so this is
what has happened since the cup uh since
the the commitment in 201 15 so this is
the amount of money soor the slides are
in front for some reason this is the
the the
uh what was sent what was spent uh so
less than 100 billion but more
importantly it is mostly loans and it's
mostly mitigation so basically we are
lending money to poor countries to
undertake Investments that are going to
help reducing the carbon in the
atmosphere for everyone so it doesn't
seem that is addressing the issue of the
the cost that we
are so I make a few points before
getting to uh to uh uh the uh to the uh
kind of proposal the first one is you
cannot we cannot tackle climate change
collectively without tackling R
distribution across countries uh that's
supp kind of a normative point of view
and also a positive uh uh position
because as you said currently the best
way to not die from hot water hot
weather is to be rich so no adaptation
fund is going to mean uh less mitigation
uh in the absence of fund for adaptation
what country want is to become rich as
fast as as fast as possible and also to
use as much energy as possible uh if you
look at the energy demand that is uh
estimated from now between 2100 is going
to be huge increase in energy demand uh
uh for countries that are hotter and
have the you know middle inome countries
that have the ability to purchase air
conditioning and to connect everyone to
energy this is India China Etc India is
is projected to have an increase in
150% almost in energy domain and they
want to do that like as quickly as
possible uh so if it takes if it is
charcoal so be it so um that's kind of
there is this clear dilemma for Emerging
Markets um say Equador wants money he
would like to not drill the Amazon but
if nobody give them money to do it they
will drill the Amazon India wants uh uh
energy and therefore at the cup 26 the
Glasgow at the very end they decided not
to sign the side with China to not sign
the the the pledge to win themselves or
charcoal and they say it's very nice but
uh the problem is we have to uh we you
know the real the thing that this sum is
like real climate was climate Injustice
so that's the first point the second
point is you cannot uh tackle climate
change without tackling rad distribution
within countries again that's a
normative point the one that L made it's
also a positive Point uh because when
you try to do something that is uh going
to address climate change there are
going to be winners and losers and
unless the losers are not pretty
convinced that they are going to make
make whole then it's just not going to
happen happen so in um in France uh the
we had this yellow jacket protest where
the people protested with their yellow
jacket and what prompted it was an
effort to have a carbon tax on gasoline
and that Caron text was removed after
about half a day but then the the
protest continued but this is what
launched it and what it said on the
jacket is money for fighting climate
change is in is to be found in fiscal
Paradise not in the pocket of the
proletariat um so this this but this is
very strong and that's true both for
carbon tax any regulation as well so
people don't want to abandon their old
car because they still need to travel
and and so
on uh in poor countries in poorer
countries it's a bit the same thing uh
so that's an example for so in in in
India Nick studied intensively there is
free power to to Farmers which is the
problem for it's even more immediate
problem for overuse of of water but all
the attempts to uh remove the subsidies
or lower the subsidy and replace them
with say cash has really have been U
really struggled in the face of very
very strong farmer opposition and which
here they call it like Midsummer Madness
so people basically do not trust that
this is something you can
do so if we take into count this two
things this is where I come to the more
kind of going on a limp it seems that
the world needs to manage to commit now
to a mechanism to raise money for a fund
which could be the loss and Recovery
Fund which would be designed to
low-income countries and within that to
low-income citizens it needs to be fair
both nationally and internationally in
ter it needs to be permanent because uh
we have already show that we cannot
renegotiate we have to have rules
otherwise it's not happening and ideally
provide some incentive to reduce
pollution along along the way because
otherwise there is this the worst case
scenario would be one where people in
rich countries feel they are now paying
for their emission and therefore they
can continue to emit peacefully because
there's
no um so how much uh uh should it so
what I want to do in my last few minutes
is say how much money is needed where we
can find it and how we would spend it so
how much money is is needed uh so the
way it's a bit for Choose Your Own
Adventure here but this is the
calculation I made very simple I'm
taking the Calton uh uh and at all
estimate of $37 of damage per ton just
from loss of life so this is not the
total social cost of carbon this is just
the cost uh that Transit from the you
know if more people die we lose the all
these statistical lives they have a
number uh this and for each ton cost us
in term of L of Life
$37 then you take the consumption
emission not the actual not the
production Mission consumption emission
if we if that's change these numbers
change they can change add them up for
us and Europe multiply by 37 and you get
to about $500 billion dollar so
unfortunately this turns out to be also
the cost that people say we need to
spend on energy transition so that
creates confusion because everybody
wants to raise $500 billion but it has
not it has nothing to do with it this is
this is not for transition this is what
we
owe uh today what we owe every year to
the poor countries uh from the fact that
we are killing them so that's that's
about so that's a lot of money just for
comparison us total foreigners is$ 56
billion so we are not in the same
bullbar now how are we find it so number
of this of options have been U discussed
uh including uh air passenger ticket
Levy
IMO Transit like ship Ley and so on um
my uh um proposal uh so I want to talk
about one little proposal that I have
and also uh something that Gabrielle
zman's outfit the EU tax Observatory
came up with the report came out uh 25
October of this this year very recent so
I just want to add that as well
uh so in uh so my my proposal is the
reason why I propos this is that I think
it would be feasible I I think it's not
crazy to think that it could happen
because in know so this is a minimum tax
on large
corporations so in October 2021 137
countries and jurisdiction agreed to
implement uh a major reform in the
international corporate tax system uh a
global minimum tax of 50 % of the
profits of the largest multinational
companies um so the way it works there
are two pillars but pillar two is the
one that raise monies so for example if
a German company pays 10% of their
profits on Singapore Germany will
collect the extra 5% so everyone gets to
gets to
15 um so my proposal for this is to uh
and just add to that and the EU
Observatory helpfully allows you to uh
to uh put your numbers you know how much
you want to raise they have simulators
for it so if the original plan was
25% just to see that minimum then it
through various negotiation went back
down to 15% suppose we go back to 20 so
you add 5% uh that's uh 400 billion EUR
right there suppose you had 3% that's
300 billion billion Euro
um if uh the US didn't want to do that
which is plausible given that they
didn't then ratifying the first one uh
the Europe only uh could do it uh uh
with two and raise 200 billion by adding
by adding 5% so the Europe EU could
could do a first uh a first uh then if
we take the The Proposal that came out
in the EU tax Observatory which is not
about climate it's about you know just
taxing people in general they uh take
the they propose they they calculate the
revenue potential of an minum tax of 2%
on the wealth of billionaires in 2023
it's 3,000 people in the world it's not
very many uh 2% wealth tax I it's it's
it's good to think about it as a 40%
income tax on the interest that
generated because rich people have very
good return on the libber on the stock
market so let's they make about
5% uh which is goes and tax because most
of it is kind of reinvested and so on if
you take about half of the 5% that
correspond to about 2% so I think about
2% wealth tax not as oh we have to uh
tax the reach above and be 2% weth tax
as well that's kind of a way of bringing
them to the type of marginal tax rate
that we pay uh um so if you did that uh
you could raise uh 258 billions per year
uh and today we already raising some
money from them so it's an extra 200 so
combine the 3% extra on the corporation
plus this 2% tax rate and we getting to
five whoops we're getting to 500 billion
relatively PL plausible even if Russia
didn't want to participate we still
would get
200 so there is a number of issues first
of all the oecd thing is you know it's
it's still in in in the making the
second big problem is that in the
original proposal the country that
enforced the tax keep it so they have a
strong incentive to do it whereas here I
would like to take this money and and
and put it to that
fund
um so the first problem is so Is it
feasible well uh the
the what I had it could be done un
unilaterally by Europe or really by any
country or group of country by adding a
tariff basically to the good that come
from countries that are not taxing at
the same level it's not great economies
do not like tariff but in in in some
sense the IRA in the US is also has a
lot of protectionist element so maybe
maybe the world is moving in a direction
where politically at a positive level
it's visible so we don't have to wait
for everybody to agree we can for the EU
for example could could do the first
step
for the second issue that it goes to
other people and would people agree and
so on so first of all it's already the
case for whatever contribution we sent
to the IMF or to the or to the World
Bank second of all there is very
interesting uh work by Adrian Fab uh and
then people don't I don't know their
first name DW and matau looking at uh uh
they have a panel of 40,000
people uh that they interview on various
issues Rel regarding climate change and
they have tremendous amount of support
for a global wealth tax on millionaire
the people to and then um so 67 in every
country in it's 67% or more uh but on
average it's more I'll show you in a in
a moment and uh and then when people so
people are asked whether they would be
in favor of a well tax on millionaire
they are in general quite favorable even
though they don't like taxes in general
so this is uh and and then when I ask
whether some of this money should go
toward the the poor uh um and about
people said that about a third of that
should go to low-income countries and I
should say it's a tax on millionaire not
billionaire so you would think that
maybe a tax on billionaire would be even
more
favorable still from that paper you can
look the the the support for various
proposal that are Global proposal
uh and you can see that where is the one
that I'm looking for um uh there is a
fair amount of support for payment from
high income country to low-income
country
um and uh next national uh the global
tax on millionaire funding low-income
country which is basically the the one
I'm proposing as uh you know the US is
the lowest support with
69% but then Europe is 84% support uh
and within Europe you see this these
different countries so there is actually
a fair amount of popular support for for
something like that which doesn't mean
plenty of ideas of popular support and
they don't happen anyway but at least
it's not going necessarily Against the
Grain
oops um then the suppose that that money
is raised the next uh oh yeah the third
issue is there's no connection to
climate change
so this I think we could imp we could we
could improve that right now I don't
think we have a great measure of of
carbon footprint of FS but if we improve
the accounting of carbon footprint of F
and now that we have the right social
cost of carbon we can uh kind of that
Corporation this corporation tax could
have a carbon tax flavor to them and
unlike the carbon tax that in general
unpopular a carbon tax which is you know
a basically maybe a rebate for firms
that are
virtuous from the minimum income tax
would work well so you could have
incentive build into the system uh
companies that improve their carbon
footprint could see their liability
reduced that would be perhaps acceptable
of course the fact taing taxing are very
very rich because they consume more and
therefore emit more is in itself uh goes
in the right direction from clim from a
carbon tax point of
view okay so now that I have my 500
billion what do we uh what do we do with
it how to spend it um it's been it's
been a it's been a very very difficult
uh debate and very angry debate in the
loss and uh uh for the loss and damage
fund that was proposed at the last cup
and it almost scuttled you know a few
weeks ago there was
a political stalemate about that thing
maybe they would not even propose it at
the next C cup and the issue was very
much like where would it leave how do it
work
etc so uh to petti has a very short
article uh uh and then took in the in a
book edited by great sber and talks also
a bit in his brief history of inequality
of something to you know raise money
from rich countries to poor countries
and that his proposal is we should just
give it to the poor countries and put it
in the budget and no question
asked uh the issue uh when we combine
with the fact that actually there is
also a ton of inequality in both
emission but also in the cost of climate
change within poor countries is whether
that would go to the poor citizen so if
we just put money in the Indian
budget are we sure that it goes to uh
some of the poorest citizen that are the
most affected by climate change so
that's so that's that that one extreme
at The Other Extreme and it seems that
we're going toward this other extreme
the World Bank sets gets it and
administer it as a fund with very little
input from the poor countries uh it has
advantages because they they have
capacity to do it and but then what the
poor countries are really objecting is
that this money is there in the sense uh
and now it's administered by you know in
in Washington DC so that's not proper
and there is a lot to say for that so
so my proposal there again for and there
I think there is Al a lot of work to do
uh and maybe I should have done this
work because maybe this is the place
where I know just uh I would know a
little more but this is where I've done
the list work is how so this is the
three things where I would spend it if I
had to think about it one of it is a
simply a um automatic transfers to
household that are triggered by climate
event so today
many more people around the world are
really connected to within like a phone
app away or in India um bank accounts uh
are reachable by
transfers so uh there could be rules
that uh the when you know as a function
of the situation in the in the
particular sub region everyone is
entitled to that uh to that transfer
uh they can even be ruled there is work
by stepen derin and others looking at
anticip transfer transfer in Bangladesh
paying people before the the event takes
place which is really helps people you
know put themsel to safety it helps with
adaptation so you don't comp compensate
people you compensate people in advance
it actually helps uh uh saving lives so
there is a lot it's not it's not true
that everyone is ready to be paid for
today there is a lot of work just money
to be spent to create the infrastructure
but it is feasible to have basically
pipelines that touch a lot of people and
we now have so much evidence that once
people get money they use it well uh
that this kind of transfer compensatory
transfer when things are going poorly uh
if possible in advance would uh B Bo
both be compensation and adaption so
that's you could probably spend un
fortunately quite a bit of money on that
because there are a lot of dis events
the second is energy access and lip
frogging uh so again I don't think
mitigation should be shouldered by poor
countries but on the other hand there is
really no reason to to do to to build
charcoal plant if you can do build a
more expensive but plant that is going
to Li frog create a good electricity
grid and so on do it with grants not
with loans and the third and that's
where I'm preaching for my
going back to the debate to the one
question that was asked about the
training is there is so much we don't
know and we are just scratching the
surface today with a great session about
something that can be done but the
research on how household can adapt uh
to climate change uh how they can
contribute to mitigation at their own
level or even how to ID is just in
infant so I think that so there have
been something like development impact
Venture AT usaid or the feed in France
have been have shown great great success
in reaching multitudes of project all
around the world really coming from the
Grassroots so for example the feed in
France most of the project that have
been proposed have been proposed from
the grassroot in Africa in regions that
are very uh affected by climate change
let this project come from everywhere uh
fund them and uh uh learn from that what
works for adaptation mitigation
compensation Etc have independent panels
so that it's not like the same
bureaucracy of the World Bank or
whatever that is seen as making
decisions try to distribute these panels
around the world that could be kind of
the third thing you do with this
money uh so let me conclude there I
think there may be a margin for Action
uh stay tuned uh it is also the case
that it's not that I have an in to
anybody who can make that happen so so
uh um part of my strategy is to jump up
and down and hope that the message gets
uh uh gets um kind of related and I know
that all of you are are part of this the
I think just putting this argument out
or That's My Hope might lead to even to
other you know not not necessarily this
but maybe other things uh to be adopted
because they kind of changed a little
bit the conversation between John ker
saying there is no way we'll beay hent
to okay but what it is that we need to
do thank
[Applause]
you that we long yeah yeah sorry so yeah
uh welcome uh Lucas back to the the uh
panel here and uh basically I have
little to say I think we have you know
15 or 20 minutes to question question so
I'd like to just engage with the
audience uh and see what you'd like to
ask about these great
presentations yeah
Ken great thank you very much for the
very impressive presentations and I
appreciate the posing of a solution
after a very sobering assessment of of
where we stand my question relates to
the this is um for uh Professor Duo uh
on the 500 billion that you posed so
that was coming from the mortality costs
uh that are being imposed upon
developing countries but that 500
billion also depends on the value of
statistical life that's assumed and
there are contentious arguments all the
time about do we count someone in Ghana
the same way as someone in the US or
much less depending on you know scale up
by their GDP so I'm wondering whether
that uh opens a can of worms by tying it
to the 500 billion to uh something that
is attached to a value of statistical
life that may be very contentious among
the people who would be receiving the
funding do you have thoughts on
this yeah great question so there's that
and then on the other hand you could say
but we know why stop at mortality we
should use the full social cost of
carbon or at least the soci social cost
of carbon as it plays out in the poor
countries
um and
I think that's maybe would be Tamar's
view or Michael G's view but um I I
think it might be uh the most helpful
way to do this and that's kind of why
where I hope to go is to Choose Your Own
Adventure you know this is this is this
is the emissions you can even go
production consumption the new the new
and improved consumption that they are
going to generate and then this is the
cost this is you know $37 for for value
of a statistical life times the
mortality damage full social cost of
carbon under value uh people in
low-income country which I wouldn't
personally do but you know someone might
want to do and that gives you a sense of
where uh how this number my my play out
for the one thing that I hope to do is
kind of build this tool all of the data
is already there to uh to do it and it
would help people uh
form their uh but at least they would
have to argue uh publicly that that's
what they chose and that would that
itself would be
interesting yes
Katherine uh fascinating proposal thank
you I I guess I'm more optimistic than
you are about carbon pricing I think in
particular the EU cbam is encouraging a
lot of countries like just yesterday
turkey announced that they're adopting
carbon pricing there are a bunch of
countries Thailand Vietnam Sagal That
that are considering carbon pricing in
response to the EU bam and there have
been bills in the US that tie carbon
price revenues to distributions to
low-income countries and I could imagine
that that would make it
more politically you know salable in in
developing countries or sorry um richer
countries that people might be you know
I think first of all like communicating
the fact that carbon pricing raise
revenue and then using that revenue for
for low-income countries could be
something that that makes it more
politically tenable in in rich
countries yeah I don't think that carbon
pricing cannot be done I think that they
they can but I'm not sure that if you
link carbon pricing to sending the money
in poor countries that would work out in
a country like in France for example
that wouldn't play out it's like
whatever I because people are so you
know the poor people they they feel so
much hardship as it is even though their
hardship is not the same as people in
ner that you know they don't want
they're not concerned about future
generation they're not particularly
concerned about people in Africa either
if they have to pay for it so so I think
carbon pricing that's another discussion
in a way I think carbon pricing can work
if you can credibly commit that the
incidence is not on the poor and I think
it has been difficult uh but it has
worked in some cases for example
Indonesia successfully removed a lot of
sub subsidies to it's not carbon pricing
but it's equivalent when they tied it to
an unconditional cash transfer and I
think there was enough trust that it
just went through Canada was able to do
that as well in the at the same time
when France tried to do car imposes
carbon tax like just before they had
removed the wealth tax so the optic of
it was it's kind of a different
discussion I think carbon pricing are
feasible but they
require a lot of trust and pedagogy and
I'm not sure that linking them to uh
poor countries would make it easier but
maybe just I mean you could read so what
what's been proposed in bills in
Congress is to like link some of it like
you know 25% or
something may maybe to to jump in here
um so I fully agree with um is there
that um um National carbon taxes um
would probably uh uh fail in so many
countries if they were tied if their
revenues were tied with uh with um uh
increased spending or donations to the
rest of the world but in the cbam so
border adjustments uh there were
proposals actually in the EU that some
of the revenues of the Border would be
used to compensate the losers because in
that case the losers are outside
basically right but that that battle so
far was lost so the EU decided to keep
the funds uh for within but I think this
is going to be an ongoing debate as
basically the rates or the implied rates
increase at the border or the types of
goods that are subject to to this
mechanism um get enlarged so I think the
same principle that applies within
countries that carbon pricing works when
the losers are well compensated CF
British Columbia for instance uh I think
it also applies pretty well in the
global stage so I think there's still
scope for these discussions to be to be
pursued in Europe and in other in other
uh regions and countries as
well
yes thank you very impressive uh
presentations thank you much indeed uh
my name is Chaba I'm coming from the
field of diplomatic struggles uh you
have you have indicated a couple of
times a couple of questions that may
help us moving forward uh
first
uh I understand that basically we are
talking about a global system of red
redistributing revenues and
incomes on National scales we have the
legal and institution system for that we
call it Taxation and social policy
do we have it on a global scale and are
we going to introduce it at global scale
the
second uh you have mentioned that in the
range of 530 560 billion doar might be
raised might be needed to make a change
uh which is about three times uh of the
size of the official
UT can you tell me one single country in
the last 70 years that came out of
poverty due to
Oda and the if uh if the tripling size
would make a
difference how that would make the
difference and uh the third one I was
very much interested in where do you see
the sources of these funds that would be
glob globally redistributed and you
never mentioned uh the petrol countries
just in the last one and a half years uh
the windfall profit was much higher than
anything else in the last 1,000 years in
the in the human history just Norway
during one and a half
year received extra windfall profit
without investment without without any
special investment that would be in real
terms real prices today much higher than
the whole Marshall Plan offered by the
US to the whole of Europe and that is
now is out of out of our
thinking thank
you yes
sure sure so we we only have a couple
minutes left so I'm just going to
collect two three questions and then
allow the panelists to to respond yeah
so cost us yeah thanks for the present
wasina the numbers for inquality
particular the numbers for inequality I
find the numbers for getting out of uh
you know the carbon cost of getting
people getting out of poverty kind of
optimistic because if we think of the
countries that you know grew fast out of
property like India China Vietnam they
went through a growth process was much
more messy and the the emissions
increased massively also for General
equilibrium reasons right like you know
you have to gener create policies that
have many repercussions of how you grow
how you emit but if this is if this is a
true critique what I'm saying then this
has implication of how do you you know
what policy should you use because
redistribution is not going to be enough
so I just wanted to hear your thoughts
about
that and I guess uh
last
you had two rules one I had one question
of my own and then there was one on Zoom
from actually uh panelist who's in the
afternoon and she sent it from India
where she stayed up late so I felt I
should ask that I think my question
which was a quick question um is that
this poverty emissions tradeoff which
I'm incredibly sympathetic to
politically otherwise my understanding
is it doesn't account for changes in
growth trajectories of these poor
countries and so you can imagine that if
nja suddenly starts growing at 20% or
something like that based on fossil fuel
development you may see very you may
actually see a genuine tradeoff and I
think that's the thing that people are
posing is not so much that if you
redistribute and B them up how much
they'll consume but rather if that
country really changes um sort of this
nature of growth so I'd love to hear
about that and then this is from uh Tel
um who's u in India she's one of the
ipcc authors in me pan in the afternoon
for Lucas does the focus on income
distributions across the world as though
we have one Global Community divided
into three classes not take away from
the fact that these Trends are still
strongly mediated by nation states how
do we connect this inequality AC
different levels of development to
nation states and then to Esther uh why
only focus on the eradication of basic
minimum of extreme poverty the study
quoted is often used to shut down
arguments of climate
justice so maybe I could ask Lucas to
respond first and then Esther to take
the several questions at
once many thanks um maybe on the first
point on the um carbon um impact of
poverty eradication and so I think this
this is a valid point um Alat and
co-authors have a paper on that uh
basically saying that uh you know after
Brookner uh that actually it might be a
little more carbon intensive
although to to me the real challenge is
uh what happens after the you know $5.5
poverty line uh and still the point that
you know below 1.9 uh it's relatively
little carbon this point is is to me
pretty pretty strong wrong the question
really is what happens what trajectories
what growth trajectories what
consumption patterns are associated with
the type of middle class or non-extreme
poor life uh we're talking about and so
that's very much uh the issue here but
not the eradication of extreme poverty
itself and I think yeah as EST was
saying we've been talking too much about
this uh the second Point uh nation state
versus uh a global social State well I
think first
there are some elements of that uh you
know very very preliminary but the
United Nations operates does some form
of redistribution and so that could also
be one of the recipients of the funds
that Esther was talking about the second
answer I think is really the duf flow
strategy of trying to bypass uh existing
mechanism and create new ad hoc one so
if you add up a layer of tax on the
corporate minimum tax that is currently
being negotiated basically no one feels
that they are losing from it except a
few company uh
shareholders but so basically you're
you're kind of um uh taming down the
potential losers from such measures but
you're still generating new funds and
you can use them in different either ad
hoc mechanisms in the UN the World Bank
or whatever but that's how I think we
can progressively move Beyond this uh
National versus International social
State discussion
yeah maybe kind of uh without doing
Justice for to all the comments um so on
this I think your question CES very much
this question which is the thing is
China and India became Rich a lot of
people became Rich it's not just the the
people below what so when we do this
calculation is really literally what
these people would consume but what
happened in China and India they had a
lot of very very very rich people also
and in fact some of the highest polluter
are in China and India now in term of
consumption Mission they have their
billionaire and they live in uh
50 floors houses and they have cars and
so on and so forth so so that's kind of
I think the distinction between the two
um so you were wondering whether there
is any precedent for international R
there is we have the UN we have the IMF
we have the World Bank there is there
there is actually the Breton wood
institution are a mechanism for Global
redistribution not very big but uh
nonetheless existing that's why I was
saying it's not uncom it's already in
the system there is pipes for sending
money for FR to the World Bank and uh
that then that money goes to poor
countries in the form of Ida so the
principles are not unheard of maybe the
the magnitudes are are different as you
pointed out um you you were asking if
anybody has proven that any country went
out of poverty with first of all I don't
think one can
prove that one way or the other because
it's not that we have a good
contactual um second of all odier is way
too small to take anybody any country
out of poverty so even this idea would
be from from richer countries we tend to
think we are so important but in term of
the budget that goes toward poor people
people in the world this is minuscule so
it's not going to take them out of
poverty if countries go out of poverty
it's because of what they do uh and if
they or something if they manage to um
fight the problems that people face in
po countries
so
um so I kind of think that's sort of a a
non question in this particular issue
and then going
back I think it's useful to represent
this idea this this this money this 500
billions it's I don't think it one thing
that I am pretty convinced there
shouldn't be counterpart that oh we give
you this money now you have to grow it's
not something that we would do out of
the goodness of our heart it's something
that we
owe whatever we can calculate how much
we owe we can argue on the we can
bargain on the on on the details but
it's not about oh I'm going to help you
but then you have to show me you're a
good student uh that's we owe that not
so much to the countries but to the
people and so the the key difficulty is
to make sure it reaches the people
whether or not the country will grow as
a result frankly I think it's besides
the point for this particular
proposal wonderful I think we'll stop
there and carry the conversation into
lunch but uh warm uh reception for our
panelists uh thank you very
[Applause]
[Music]
much